[Musique]
bonsoir pour poser complètement
l'ambiance
je vous préviens je suis venu en tongs
pour ceux du fond en tongs
j'ai pas hésité une seule seconde c'est
ça le pire
je suis venu en tongs pour vous parler
d'élégance ok attendez je me suis dit
ils vont comprendre que je suis en tongs
et vont le voir je vais le leur dire et
ils vont se regarder et vont dire à
leurs voisins mais on est sûr sûr à 100%
que ça c'est une grande journaliste de
mode
non parce qu'elle aurait quand même pu
faire un effort même arène
et j'en ai fait un effort et vous avez
raison il faut faire un effort pour être
élégant sauf que c'est pas du tout du
tout l'effort qu'on croit et notamment à
paris
alors évidemment souvent on me demande
qui j'ai trouvé dans ma carrière puisque
jeune carrière j'ai vu beaucoup de
défilés de mode
j'ai vu des gens supposent est bien
habillé et souvent on me demande mais
qui vraiment a marqué par son élégance
il ya trois exemples qui me viennent en
tête toujours le premier c'est une jeune
femme dans une rue de kinshasa
je les ai vus sur instagram c'est une
jeune tout jeune fille elle a une jupe
noire trapèze
elle a une chemise rose elle a un petit
bibi rose sur la tête et là des sandales
de plastique
on comprend très bien que c'est une
personne qui n'a pas beaucoup d'argent
et elle est divine
la seconde personne que j'ai en tête
alors là c'est complètement un autre
milieu social et notre histoire c'est
l'actrice monica vitti et en plus est
une icône de style c'est facile mais
l'image que j'ai d'elle en tête
c'est sur le tournage d'un film modestie
blaise où elle porte une chemise de nuit
blanche en crépon blanc je connais ces
détails et aux pieds elle à akwa des
tongs
j'ai fait exprès est la dernière
personne qui me vient à l'esprit
j'adore c'est un homme en crète j'étais
parti en fin de l'hiver en crète et dans
le village où j'étais tous les hommes
étaient habillés pareils vachement bien
il était tout en noir avec une grosse
coiffe noire
cet homme là il était comme les autres
sauf que lui
qu'est ce qu'il avait fait il était allé
se coller un coquelicot dans son chapeau
mais vous savez combien de temps sa vie
un coquelicot une fois que c'est que
ying rien même pas une minute à lui
pour le temps aux ça durait est allé
choisi comme ça se donner un genre
ces trois personnes elles ont quelque
chose en commun
c'est qu'en fait pour les cas qui nous
occupe même pour monica vitti sur son
tournage ils ont fait avec les moyens du
bord
puis ça nous parle parce qu'on sait tous
on l'a tous l'exemple dans notre famille
dans notre entourage
on sait tous qu avec les moyens du bord
c'est comme ça qu'on fait des miracles
n'est ce pas qu'on sait tous et pourtant
alors là vous allez m'expliquer pourquoi
alors qu'on le sait tous la publicité
les magazines de mode les lois du
commerce
tout ça arrive parfois à nous faire
douter on vous dit c'est beau la chemise
du diobass a peu vu ce que ça a coûté
donc on se fait on est des idiots en
fait on se fait avoir on a l'impression
qu'il faut y mettre le prix
vous savez c'est quand on voit dans un
magazine de mode 1 il ya une page
et puis dans la page et un sac mis en
grand avec un gros logo dessus et puis
tout aussi gros à côté un peu moins cons
que le logo il ya écrit on le veut tout
non
on ne veut pas tout pardon d'abord il
est moche et reçues qui coûte 2000 euros
donc il faudrait mettre tout virgules on
le veux pas comme on peut pas la voir en
plus c'est facile de dire ça
[Musique]
bah oui mais c'est drôle sauf que moi
j'ai passé ma vie
coincé entre une idée de l'élégance et
le monde de la mode pour lequel je
travaille
d'un côté j'avais cette idée de
l'élégance qui me vient de ma grand mère
ma grand mère c'était ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui une migrante
on disait réfugiés à l'époque dans les
années 20 elle avait vraiment pas
l'argent ni le temps de s'acheter un
magazine de mode
alors alors regarder les femmes
boulevard montparnasse elle envoyait
syfy pour regarder comment cet effet les
petits plis les petites pinces pour leur
faire elle se faisait ses habits et elle
me disait avec son accent arménien elle
me disait illégaux ans c'est luxe plus
abordable tu peux t'offrir l'élégance
c'est le luxe le plus abordable que tu
puisse offrir
merci pour elle oui mais bon d'un autre
côté j'avais notre milieu l'autre monde
le monde de la mode et je me suis battu
pour entrer dans ce monde et le monde de
la mode c'était celui qui disait qu' il
fallait s'acheter des choses beaucoup de
choses
il fallait les acheter cher et y mette
le prix il fallait acheter les marques
et moi j'ai adoré aussi ce monde là je
dois dire
mais un jour je suis devenu dingue entre
ma grand mère et mes collègues j'ai plus
pu tenir et j'étais même été obligé de
démissionner démissionner alors que
j'étais à la tête du journal
quel gâchis moi c'était ce moment là que
mon frère figurez-vous s'est débarrassé
d'un grand miroir
alors il m'a appelé et m'a dit écoute
n'ont même pas appeler il est venu il
m'a dit que voilà j'ai un grand miroir
je voulais que je t'ai je vais mettre
chez toi charmant alors moi j'étais
devant ce miroir qui l'avait mis dans ma
chambre je me suis regardé dans ce
miroir j'étais comme ça je dis vraiment
c'est vraiment c'est la loose j'ai perdu
mon travail j'ai perdu confiance en moi
quand même au passage je me dis pas par
pudeur est maintenant plus je sors de
poubelles à mon frère
et puis
je sais pas la vie elle vous fait des
cadeaux j'étais devant ce miroir et je
me suis dit et si en fait comme ma grand
mère et si j'essayais de me réparer par
l'élégance alors là ni vu ni connu
chiffon soeur mon placard j'ai pris des
choses que j'avais chine et ça c'est
saint laurent mais c'est chine est en
fait 20 euros et je suis revenu je me
suis foutu devant mon miroir habillés
mais vraiment en leur racontant j'ai
fait ma crâneuse personne ne me
regardait cette est facile de faire ma
crâneuse geffray une photo
j'étais enchanté je voulais poster sur
instagram gémit j'ai essayé d'être
élégante
j'avais peu de fowler à l'époque mais
enfin c'est incroyable les réactions que
j'ai eue alors ça m'a encouragé le
lendemain j'ai recommencé
voilà j'ai encore essayé d'être élégante
et juju compte recommencer recommencer
et on est trois ans plus tard il y à 180
milles personnes qui tous les jours vous
regardez comment je m'en sors ça m'aide
à m'en sortir
et il est là l'effort il est là l'effort
c'est que je fais l'effort d'essayer
d'être élégante
je le fais je vous jure avec le pied
cassé je le fais avec le moral cassé je
le fais alors que je n'ai plus 20 ans
comme vous le voyez et je le fais alors
que je doute fort d'être belle comme
j'espère que vous le voyez - je le fais
cet effort tous les jours j'essaie de
m'arranger là je suis arrangé je vous
jure c'est pas fini y en a peut-être
qu'on applaudit et qu'ils disent à
ranger arranger attend canteleu 10 mais
on s'en fiche
parce que le plus important c'est le
plaisir que j'y prends et c'est le
plaisir que ce soir j'arrive à partager
avec vous parce qu'il se trouve que vous
aussi vous pouvez vous la racontez vous
aussi vous avez un miroir vous aussi
vous avez des tongs
vous aussi vous pouvez vous mettre
devant votre miroir aux jo personnes
vous regarde vous mettez les vêtements
de quelqu'un d'autre de la famille
personne n'en saura jamais rien et vous
faites une photo vraiment comme dans les
magazines mais où peut-être une photo
comme sur une photo de jacques henri
lartigue vous faites la photo vous la
regardez cette photo ensuite et vous
allez voir ce que vous allez découvrir
vous allez découvrir une personne
inoubliable il put 1 c'est vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]